charli's how are you talking to your
kids right now what's going on in the
world there was a moment where I felt
like a little piece of my children's
innocence or taken from them during this
period because I have to sit down with
them and have really really hard honest
conversations about some really ugly
things in our world today but they need
to know and I want them to know because
I want to raise two little warriors my
girls know that they have a place in
this world and they need to stand up
tall and strong and proud and and that
is that's the most important thing right
now raising strong and self-reliant
women that's the goal for Charlize and
she leads by example in her new Netflix
film the old guard
she's a butt-kickin action hero I lead a
group of soldiers with an extremely rare
skill set let's just say we're very hard
to kill gotta talk about these fight
scenes you all mix it up
where their bruises did you take a
beatin in this one because I know you'd
like to do your own stunts yeah I
definitely had a couple of bruises that
were that were quite shocking a hide a
small injury on my hand but nothing you
know nothing that was like incredibly
crazy keke how was it for you definitely
walked away with a few bruises myself
but uh nothing that scared me away from
doing more action films Charlize and
Kiki Lane hit the gym hard prepping to
play immortal mercenaries in this
action-packed thriller it starts
dreaming July 10 one of the things that
jumped out at me is the subtle diversity
of this film how important was that to
you Kiki in making this I mean extremely
important because it's real you know for
whatever reason Hollywood has had a very
limited view of what life is in this
film basically says no there is so much
more room so many more people that can
fill those roles and tell those stories
my girls came out when we made this film
and I just loved that my children you
know will look back on this film and
that and see themselves reflected Kiki
is a reflection from my girls in this
film and that's so important we need
more of that
Charlize real quick I always ask you
this question
after quarantine do you think there'll
be a man who will step up and be the man
that you want him to be listen if that
is what I want when foreign scene is
over then maybe that will happen
[Music]